And if we can somehow extract what is
positive from a,
what is called religion,
that it might,
it leads us to ideas such as fraternity,
unity,
oneness,
compassion,
and like,
uh,
we do you not find a and connections
between what you have learned in
neuroscience and what you have learned
from studying sort of Buddhism?
Oh yeah.
The connections are very direct,
but
how they know that stuff,
but we will,
but we don't want just because it's,
it's just the nature of consciousness is
the,
you're talking about people who spent,
especially in the Buddhist case,
a,
just an incredible amount of time
studying from,
um,
from the first person side what
experiences,
like what his character is.
The central claim of Buddhism is not
just Buddhism but,
but Buddhism.
And I would put several of the Indian
traditions like Advaita Vedanta in there
with the central claims that the,
the self is an illusion.
The EGO is an illusion.
Where.
And when I say self,
I don't mean that people are illusions.
I mean that the sense that you have a
subject riding around in your head
thinking your thoughts rather than that
there's a thinker in addition to the
thoughts.
That's an illusion and that makes
perfect sense neurologically because
there's no.
There's no place in the brain for your
ego to be sitting.
There's no central place where
everything comes together.
There's no unchanging center in the
brain.
You're just talking about a cascade of
neurophysiology and everything is
distributed everywhere and it's not a
and there are various parts of the brain
that are coming online and off and and
and subserving conscious dates and not.
It's,
it's a,
it's a process and there is there.
If you could experience consciousness as
a flow of sensory and emotional and
interoceptive experience without a.
The sense that there's an unchanging
center riding around on that flow,
right?
Like a man in a boat on the,
on the stream of consciousness.
If you could experience that
consciousness without that,
that would be an experience that is much
more coincidence with what we understand
neurologically.
That would be.
That would be to experience something
that is more true from the third person
brain based,
what do we see inside the head side,
and it just so happens you can't
experience that.
That is just.
That is how that is what meditation is
like when you really know how to
meditate.
This sense that there's a meditator in
the head strategically paying attention
to experience rather than just pure
experience that drops away.
Right?
So that's this one.
That's one piece of data in favor of,
of the of introspection here and it's
not.
It's not a piece that the western
intellectual tradition or the West or
the western spiritual tradition ever got
a good hand handle on.
I mean,
so yes,
you can find specific Christian and
Jewish and Muslim mistakes making these
noises,
but they make the.
When they make these noises
sufficiently,
they start to sound like Buddhists and
they're co-religionists want to kill
them rather often.
Religionists powerful within nation
states in economic life,
people stopped believing they're not
individuals.
It's very out to market at them.